Leviathan is usually looked at and
taught as mainly a piece of social and
political philosophy so you might wonder
why Hobbes is beginning it especially
these first five chapters with a lot of
discussions that would seem to be more
in the realm of metaphysics and even
more epistemology explaining for example
where our ideas come from how we get
them how we can evaluate them even if
you think about what his project is he's
trying to provide a comprehensive
philosophy not just a social and
political philosophy not even something
broader in terms of moral philosophies
so including ethics as well but
something even more expansive even more
encompassing that includes a metaphysics
and an epistemology and even something
like a logic and a discussion about
language why is he doing that because he
wants to articulate what he thinks for
the first time a truly scientific view
on the world and when we think about
science today we're often quite
distanced from what they understood
science to mean back in the 17th century
when there you know really at the
beginnings of what we call modern
science and they were seeing science as
the way to approach reality itself to
make sense of everything including human
beings and their thoughts and their
activities Hobbes is going to adopt what
we call a materialist point of view so
he's very different than somebody like
say Descartes who adopts a dualist point
of view where body and mind are
different kinds of substances for Hobbes
there is only material substance that is
all there truly is there's nothing like
a spirit or a soul or you know as
somebody also put it later on a ghost in
the machine
everything must be explicable in terms
of matter because that's all there there
really is and matter is capable of
taking on
Keeler's shapes particular
configurations matter interacts causally
with other bits of matter so there's
Kwas and effect going on matter is at
least in principle observable and
measurable so on the one hand we can
reduce everything to what we can see
here smell you know the things that come
into the realm of the senses on the
other hand we as human beings are able
to develop what we might call laws or or
regularities dealing with the kinds of
material objects that we encounter and
how they interact with each other the
cause-and-effect connections between
them and we can also apply this to
herself and that's where Hobbes is is
beginning a lot of people wanted to do
science by carrying out experiments and
you know doing observations and that's
great that's part of science but Hobbes
is interested primarily in the creature
that does science the creature that is
capable although it usually isn't doing
this is capable of developing scientific
knowledge and a scientific perspective
upon things so if we think about what
materialism entails what we have going
on you know are just bodies or corporeal
substances and they're related to each
other in terms of cause and effect one
body affects another body you know for
example by well you know I write on the
board with the chalk I'm wearing off a
bit of the truck that's why you actually
see these lines here isn't it if it
didn't do that then we wouldn't have any
sort of writing you know if I do this
it's just a racist instead of writing
now there's a causal connection there
and there's an even more interesting
causal connection given that you're
watching this and you're seeing these
lines here because that means that
something inside of you is being
affected by something out here and
you're not even like touching it you
know in the sense that like you
you're extending out through the camera
your materially here in this place the
way I am as I write on the board and yet
your mind is being affected by these
physical phenomena that's because Hobbs
would say your mind itself as a physical
phenomena we're going to get to that in
a moment first I want to look at these
these ideas here a little bit more so
you know oftentimes you know we can a
very long causal chains where one thing
about a pool table right and doing trick
shots you hit one ball you're using the
stick to hit a ball the cue ball that
cue ball goes and hits another ball
maybe it doesn't hit the one that you
were aiming at alright well we'll make
it a little bit funny in this case so
you're aiming yet at the eight ball
because you're going to win the game and
you you do a bad shot and instead you
hit your opponent's ball and let's say
they're stripes so you hit the 15 ball
now the 15 ball is bouncing all around
the table and it hits another ball and
that hits another ball and then it's
another ball finally it hits your eight
ball sinks the eight ball but you lose
right because that was slop you know in
pool parlance right you didn't call that
shot but there's this long causal chain
of bodies affecting bodies affecting
bodies affecting bodies it can get more
complicated than man because of body
especially like a human body is actually
a very complex machine Hobbes will have
a rather outdated viewpoint on this he
thinks of nerves for example is
something like pulleys you know and
strings and now we know it's electrical
impulses but the same basic idea still
holds for much of what we think about at
least with the respect to the human body
the human body is in fact something like
a very complex very complicated can a
connection of systems that are
interrelated with each other which can
be understood along the lines of
mechanism that's why we can do things
like create an artificial heart which is
a mechanism it replaces the mechanism of
the heart is everything reducible to
mechanism Hobbes thinks that it is so
we're going to go along with that that's
a bigger question that we're not going
to try to approach here let's think
about how it would work them so if you
have some sort of system like a human
body you have one thing on the outside
and it's affecting a part of the human
body and then that part affects another
part of the human body and perhaps you
know there's even a more complex
interaction so that these parts you know
have a feedback loop or even make it as
complicated as you like maybe there's
governor's maybe there's all sorts of
interesting mechanistic features to this
but the idea is that within the human
body there are all these parts that are
connecting with each other and relating
to each other in causal ways so think
for example of your fear reaction I'd
jump at you
right and now you you can't actually
encounter me because you're watching on
the video but I jumped at you and maybe
you have a reaction the startled
reaction and maybe because you are
taking in this image with your senses
that's a part of you you suddenly have
the fight-or-flight response and you had
a lot of adrenaline go through your
system that's another part of you or a
whole set of parts of you and now maybe
that provoked you to think dr. Sandler
is a jerk or boy that was a good example
well that would be other parts of you
working as well now how do we get to
these other parts thinking about you
know thoughts thinking about complex
ideas that we have so I've got a diagram
here this is oversimplifying quite a bit
but this is more or less tracing out the
progress of what's going on in chapters
one through five of Leviathan if we look
at this chapter one we have the external
world and the human being is a thing
within the world but the human being is
almost you know you might say in a world
within itself as well it's permeable to
the outside world for example objects
you know have some
cause and they produce effects within us
of the senses so you see this whiteness
of the chalk an example that I've used
so many times you're hearing the words
that I'm speaking you see the light
shining off of my face but not so much
off of the dark corduroy of the jacket
that you perceive perhaps as a blueness
or a blackness you're you're being
affected by certain things now you know
we understand at this point that that
light is a matter of photons or waves
depending on how you want to look at it
and there's a complex clausal
interaction that takes place there and
we don't have to go into Hobbes didn't
have that that optics science available
for him at that's fun but what he didn't
understand is that the senses are
activated by external things and once
they're activated they are activated
materially he says the cause of sense is
the external body or object which
presses the organ proper to each sense
either immediately as in taste or touch
I'm touching the paper and I feel that
it's smooth right give myself a paper
cut hopefully I won't do that with this
you know I can feel the roughness of it
there that's why you get a paper cut or
immediately as in seeing hearing and
smelling you know there there's some
sort of mediation of the sound waves or
the light waves smell there's odors
being born in the air and he says this
pressure by the mediation of the nerves
and other Springs and membranes of the
body continued inward to the brain and
the heart problem seemed to think of the
heart had something to do with thinking
now we don't worry about that although
people are talking now but the gut
actually doing something aren't they
causes their resistance or counter
pressure the endeavor of the heart to
deliver itself which endeavor because
onwards seemeth to be some matter
without and this seeming or fancy is
what men call sense and consistent as to
the eye in a light or a color figure to
the ear to a sound how's it saying what
things affect us physically
and that's what produces for us
sensations like touch or taste or
hearing or sight so we have at one level
the senses right and animals share these
as well some animals have many senses
some have different senses than we do
you know for example butterflies
apparently you can see ultraviolet so
flowers look different to them takes
heavily you know a sense of pressure and
and heat and they they don't even really
know you know what's up and what's down
they certainly can't see you when
they're biting you
they have very you know primitive
instincts suck blood reproduce but all
of these can be understood in terms of
material functions and mechanism so now
when we get away from this when we go to
chapter 2 which is called on imagination
Hobbes is going to reflect upon how we
get past the immediacy of the senses now
he doesn't use those terms and why am I
talking about this immediacy of the
senses well you know right now for
example you're seeing me hold my hands
up 10 fingers in count if you like now
they're going
can you remember those 10 fingers sure
of course you can now how are you able
to do that if all you could do was
perceive through the senses you wouldn't
be able to retain anything that then you
could compare it how would you know that
this is the same ten fingers as
previously that requires more complex
operations that requires you might say
an overcoming of immediacy a / Durance
of the mind through time and that has to
do with what he is willing to call
memory but also calls imagination and
that deals with images these are what he
calls decayed sense so you know the
objects when they're affecting the sense
it's very vivid you see the light of the
paper here right now just a mad
the white of the paper it's not quite so
bright it's not quite so distinct how
many words are on this this sheet
Wow who knows right probably 500 or 600
you could count them out but now just
imagine yourself a sheet of paper with
500 words on it you can do that but
again it's not going to be quite as
distinct it's kind of fuzzy it's kind of
indeterminate those are images those are
things that are going on within our body
or Hobbes would say within our brain
that are preserving the motions of you
know what originally came to us from
outside objects through sense so memory
when we remember something we're
bringing back something that we
originally sensed you burn yourself on a
hot stove the next time you get near a
hot stove and you see a glowing red you
remember oh man that hurt like hell I'm
not putting my hand on there again you
probably did something like that when
you were a kid with me it was actually
ploy plugging the keys into the electric
socket and I only had to do that once in
part because we acquire memory now the
imagination is a faculty that can do
more than just remember it can break
things down and put them back together
again so we have some interesting
examples here for you know for example a
centaur have you ever seen a centaur I
don't mean in cartoons or in movies you
ever seen a centaur in real life no you
can't because they don't exist as far as
we know but can you imagine a centaur
yeah of course you can use it well
that's because I saw them you know a
Narnia movie wherever they were centaurs
or I you know I watch these television
shows or I watch you know cartoons in
which they they happen or you know read
comic books well somebody had to imagine
that didn't they in order to put that
down how did they do that in imagination
when it's being productive we're taking
what's originally coming from the
external world and we're perceiving
through our senses and we're taking
those images or
breaking them apart analyzing them and
then we're synthesizing them back into
new unities so now imagine a spider that
is 30 feet high and climbs on the
skyscrapers in New York City but instead
of shooting webs out of thought of it's
you know spinnerets shoots confetti and
cotton candy
now you've never seen anything like that
in your life right I don't think you
ever will almost why don't you becomes
wildly successful and you know carries
out some crazy genetic experiments to
make something like that happen I think
you do remind me of it later on if you
can track me down but what you did there
is you you used your imagination to put
together this whole complex of images we
also do that unconsciously Hobbes says
when we dream when we're dreaming our
minds are actually taking all sorts of
bits and pieces of things and they may
be also affected by external objects you
know it's cold so he's got an example of
you it's cold you dream about you know
fear because your body is being affected
but you know there's the we have a whole
stack of images that we we play around
with in our sleep but that's why I her
dreams are so so nutty so crazy
according to Hobbes he says here we go
it's it's a hard matter and by many
thought impossible to distinguish
exactly between sense and dreaming for
my part when I consider that in dreams I
do not often or constantly think of the
same persons places actions and objects
as I do waking or remember so long a
train of coherent thoughts dreaming as
at other times and because waking I
often observe the absurdity of dreams I
am well satisfied that being awake I
know I dream not though when I dream I
think myself awake when we're dreaming
we actually believe the crazy nonsense
that's come out around us and we often
don't question it if we do question it
then we can actually have lucid dreams
which Hobbs doesn't talk about here but
it's an interesting phenomenon now he
brings up another thing which is really
important experience
when we remember things over time
because we're observing many similar
things happening when were placed in
situations where we're having the same
kind of sense perceptions we start to
accumulate what he calls experience he
says much memory or memory of many
things is called experience he's quoting
somebody else at that point that's why
it's in quotation marks because that was
a common place so he says again
imagination being only of those things
which have been formally perceived by
sense either all at once survived parts
at several times the former which is the
imagining the whole object is was
presented the sense of simple
imagination and you know we eventually
acquire experience he goes on and he's
going to talk about this a bit later on
I want to to hit on this he talks about
the role of prudence when he was talking
about the train of thoughts so he says
here we go
as we acquire experience this is in
Chapter three he says we begin to think
about causes and effects we begin to
think about how things produce each
other and we can do this in a very
systematic way or we can do this in a
kind of on-the-spot way but human beings
are the kind of animals that that do
this more than other animals that's part
of why we're able to have the advances
that we do so he says as we do this we
eventually acquire what we call
foresight or food prudence or or
Providence this is a faculty or a
facility of figuring out what's going to
happen next or what must have been the
case now is this always you know going
to be correct
no this as a matter of fact if we're if
we're generalizing too much from too
narrow a range of experiences it's very
easy for us to go astray this is how
people get themselves in trouble all the
time we actually make
movies about this right somebody grows
up a certain way everybody behaves
towards each other according to certain
norms suddenly they're in the big city
or they're in the countryside or they're
in a foreign country and people act
differently and they're at a loss
because they can't rely on their
experience any any longer but experience
plays a major role in Hobbes's
understanding of human beings prudence
is this ability to think out what would
be good for ourselves what would be bad
for ourselves that's going to have a
major significance for his ethics and
his political philosophy let's go back
now to other parts of chapter three so
he's going to talk about what he
describes as the train of imagination or
the train of thought nobody's talking
about train think of the literal train
with boxcars connected to each other and
they're all going the same direction
Hobbes of course didn't have that in
mind because trains locomotives didn't
exist at that time but but the notion of
train something following something else
he had that and we can talk about a
train of imagination and we can talk
about more complex trains of thought we
can also talk about trains words and
that's going to assume a very important
place as we move further so he says when
we think about something it leads us to
thinking about something else and
something else now it can go one of two
ways sometimes we're just kind of
sitting there daydreaming and our
thoughts are wandering as we say right
but it's never quite so so random or
coincidental
there's always going to be some sort of
train that we can follow out if we do
enough work and realize why we went from
this slot all the way over to this line
but it does at least seem kind of random
a lot of the time though we're thinking
and we're relying on imagination or
relying on our experience or we might
even be doing reasoning because we want
to figure something out
were motivated much of our thinking in
life is actually motivated just like you
know right now you're paying attention
to this video why are you doing that
because you want to understand hops why
are you doing that we can trace it up
further well I've got to pass this class
where it's important to understand the
history of ideas those are what Hobbes
calls heads or goals in this piece an
end is something that we take as a good
for ourselves as something that
motivates us something that gives us a
reason to do something so he says when
when our train of thought is regulated
by some desire and some design we're
trying to work something out
and this can be all different sorts of
things it could be trying to figure out
you know what time do I need to make the
bread so that it'll be fresh when
somebody gets home whether I should go
to the store today or not whether the
person you know approaching me in the
dark alley is likely to attack me or
perhaps is going to guide me to a safer
place all of these are the sorts of
things that we carry out thinking about
if I want to date somebody how can I
actually present myself and the best way
to them and avoid having them see my
defects until you know they might be
more receptive to that sort of thing we
do a lot of thinking we don't realize
this but we're always engaged in some
sort of thinking about something early
so he says from desire arises the
thought of some means we've seen produce
the like of that which we emit and from
the thought of that the thought of that
means to that means so continually until
we come to some beginning within our own
power so let's take dating for example
right dating is a source of much anxiety
for many people early on after a while
when you acquire more experience it can
it can stop being so although if you
have the wrong kind of experience I
suppose it could become even more
anxiety producing again so you know
think about when you were when you were
you know very young and you had your
first crushes you know maybe in
elementary school or middle school or
high school they were different kinds of
at those different stages so let's say
high school right yeah let's say you
work you know that experienced in the
dating game by high school which might
be a big assumption for some people
wouldn't be for me because I wasn't so
you know you you see somebody and you
think I mean I I'm really attracted to
them how can I get involved with them
okay so now you start thinking about
well that requires this and that
requires this and maybe you are thinking
how do we do that all we go on a date
how did you know to go on a date
well you observe other people and you
see that you know going on dates can be
an integral part in getting to know
somebody and getting involved with them
and having your relationship right so
then you start thinking okay so gotta
have a date with them what do I need to
do in order to have a date why I've got
ask them but that's kind of scary how
should I do that they don't even really
know who I am maybe what I should do is
break the ice somehow by talking about
the class that we're in together because
we're in biology or we're in chemistry
or we're in you know modern literature
together right and that'll break the ice
and then I can say oh by the way see
what's going on there is you're thinking
about the end that you want which is an
effect when you're thinking about the
cause which is a means and the further
cause and the further cause until it
becomes something that you actually can
accomplish and then you hope all these
things will fall into place as it turns
out usually it's a great so simple as
that right and every juncture there's
there's a possibility for things to go
straight but notice what's happening
there you're carrying out a a reasoning
process a thought process he says the
Train of regulated thoughts is of two
kind one would have an effect imagine we
seek the causes or means that produce it
like I am attractive this person how can
I get the date how can I be in a
relationship with them the other is what
imagining anything whatsoever we seek
all the possible effects that can buy it
be produce that is the same we imagine
what we can do that when we
you're walking along you run into a
piece of chalk and you go well that's
interesting what are what I can do with
this you know and if you're if you're
kind of Daffy do you say oh maybe it
tastes great chalk doesn't taste good
I know I guess you know I was again and
tried it out kids also do things like
putting the chalk in their ears or you
know other places but then sooner or
later you start thinking wow wait a
second I've seen stuff like this before
this can do that
look that's cause-and-effect reasoning
again now it gets more interesting as we
go on Hobbes is going to talk about
language or as he calls it speech
there's a connection for Hobbes between
words and thoughts as a matter of fact
he's willing to say that all that's
happening over here can be understood as
mental discourse like a talking to
yourself inside of your head we can also
talk to ourselves and to others out in
the world using language as I'm doing
right now with you this also has trains
and these can mimic each other as a
matter of fact for Hobbes most of our
thinking is actually done through words
through language you know we have some
stuff at this lower level that might be
you know not so much done in terms of
language but although it could be framed
in terms of it I see a white thing here
that's language right experience you
know acting in terms of prudence
sometimes you just have kind of a
feeling about things you don't just
spell it out but you could in fact spell
it out if you wanted to you could make
an explicit a lot of the time we're
actually reasoning or thinking or you
know working out things through language
so this leads us to you know some some
really important points that he's making
here about the uses and abuses of
language I'm not going to go through all
the
the discussions that he has here because
I want to keep this fairly short but
notice that in this chapter four he is
going to talk about ways in which
language sometimes leads us astray in
our thinking we assume that because
there's a word for something there must
actually be a thing corresponding to
that for example or are we engaged in
what he calls them certainiy where we
were putting things together that don't
really match like when you say square
circle you can say square circle right
and you can try to imagine square circle
to yourself or you know to pick another
famous example wouldn't iron but there
isn't any such thing because there can't
be any such thing it's it's absurd it
doesn't it doesn't map on to reality
it's impossible to get these things to
juxtaposed or coincide so it's very
important that we'd be attempted to -
what language offers us and where can
lead us astray
now Hobbes is going to go on and talk
about one other thing that that's very
important and that is reason or
reasoning he'll say this is in Chapter
five of reason and science he says when
a person reasons he does nothing else
but conceive a sum total and he's got
this this analogy here to mathematics he
says from addition of parcels or
conceived a remainder from subtraction
of one sum from another and he says if
it be done with words its conceiving the
consequence of all the names of the
parts - the name of the whole he's got a
somewhat complicated way of - talking
about this essentially what he's saying
is when we're reasoning we're doing
something analogous to mathematics we're
adding and subtracting we're multiplying
and dividing and what are we doing that
with we're doing it with his words or
we're doing it with thoughts and quite
often we're using the words in order to
get at the thoughts we write our our
thinking down when you put together a
pro and con list you're carrying out a
process of reasoning according to Hobbes
and he says that
what we're doing there is putting things
together in more and more complicated
arrangements or structures he talks
about the syllogism right he talks about
adding together two names to make an
information what is adding together two
names to make an affirmation the chalk
is white chalk is one word white is
another word the chalk is white is an
affirmation that shock is not green
that's a negation the chalk is white all
white objects are beautiful therefore
the chalk is beautiful that's what we
call a syllogism that is reasoning and
much of our reasoning table says has to
do with causes and effects because
that's what we're you know particularly
interested in now he says something else
that's very important here when we when
we notice that all people reason that's
not the same thing as saying that they
all have the Faculty of Reason developed
to the same extent that takes work that
takes the development of what he calls
science and a scientific viewpoint on
things is you might say the higher
expression of this human capacity of
reason that chains things down in words
where there are no or there are fewer
and fewer because we're trying to strip
them away absurdities and things can be
made clear so let's think for example
something that can be understood in
terms of science
besides the human body besides the human
mind let's think about now
metallurgy right early on people started
figuring out you can mix metals together
they would melt at certain temperatures
someone could mix with each other some
couldn't they would have certain
properties that they would confer
eventually they start figuring out even
more complex things like if you add
carbon to iron it becomes this this
harder and you know you can make a much
sharper instrument out of it that we
call you know the
metal that we call steel and there's
different ways of doing that and they
start understanding things like well you
can fold it and make something even
sharper that way and we keep going on
and on and on with this sort of thing
and eventually we get something that we
call metallurgy a whole science a whole
art that is based on human reasoning now
that's very different than just relying
upon experience you know the first early
people that that figured out that you
could melt or I mean that must have been
quite difficult to determine you know
how do you know that you get these
stones and you get metal coming out of
them you definitely get the fire pretty
hot there had to be a lot of experiments
taking place that were kind of and
random people probably didn't pay
attention a lot of the time but
eventually they had some stock of
experience that doesn't tell you though
how do you do the the next war how do
you combine things together science a
comprehensive systematic understanding
of things is something that has to
develop through a lot of reasoning and
so Hobbes is going to talk about this
towards the end he says reason is not as
sense and memory born with us nor gotten
by experience only as Prudence's but
attained by industry first an apt
imposing of names secondly by getting a
good and orderly method in proceeding
from the elements which are names and
going out and on and on and on then he
says an eventually we arrive at what men
call science science is the knowledge of
consequences and of dependence of one
fact upon another by which out of that
we can present out of that we can
presently do we know how to do something
else when we will or the like another
time we can move outward we can expand
our realm of knowledge using science
that's that's a feature of it that takes
us far beyond mere prudence or
experience
now why is Hobbes been so keen on
explaining all this because he takes
what he's doing here as actually being
science he
trying to provide us with an
understanding not only how our body and
mind are really the same thing and how
they work but what his work Leviathan is
trying to do